(soft music)
I've answered most of my questions online,
but I'm just gonna start with the issue of the progesterone
and breast cancer.
Just to review that one more time.
So in the Women's Health initiative,
it was in the treatment arm,
you either got estrogen plus progesterone or estrogen,
depending on whether you had a uterus
or no uterus, respectively.
It was the women in the,
who had the uterus who were on estrogen plus progesterone
who had nine additional cases of breast cancer
per 10,000 patient years, okay.
Not the women in the estrogen-only arm,
they had a decreased risk of breast cancer, okay?
So it is the progesterone that drove
or drives the development of the breast cancer.
Remember, it was nine cases of breast cancer
for 10,000 patient years, not nine deaths.
So they were increased risk of breast cancer,
but not a breast cancer death, okay?
That's because we've had great treatment benefits
in terms of breast cancer.
With that, I'm gonna turn it over to Dr. Vail.
All right, the first one I wanna answer is the,
do the GLP show sustained weight loss
or are they also subject
to rebound weight gain after you stop them?
All right.
So we just saw the SURMOUNT trials come out on tirzepatide,
and what they did was they continued
after they got to their goal weight,
they stopped some of the patients
and continued some on the same dose they were on,
and the patients who stopped started gaining weight again.
And the patients that they continued on had this continued
slow kind of trending of weight loss.
No one has looked at what we're going to do with these.
Are we gonna, should we put them on a low dose
of these medicines?
Should we use the medicine once a month?
We have no data on any of that.
But the answer, the short answer is yes,
we're gonna see rebound weight gain.
Hopefully, some of these patients have, you know,
the weight loss has taken a, you know, a couple of years
to get to where they, we stopped the medicine,
and hopefully, some of those people have made enough
lifestyle change that they'll do a better job
of keeping the weight off.
Which is the issue with the payment right now,
because when you'd come off,
then you gain the weight back.
And we don't have, Belinda says,
we don't know what the data looks like.
Do I need to stay on this for the rest of my life
and what that's gonna look like?
Okay, that's the problem
in terms of 3rd party payment right now so.
Do, oh, you-
No, go ahead, Dr. Vail.
So will limited weight gain also prevent obesity
in children whose mothers are overweight
or obese going into pregnancy?
So the answer is actually yes.
It gives them a better starting point
than if you just let mothers gain weight at, you know,
crazy rates during their pregnancy,
but once they're born, then you've got,
then now you have a whole new set of things.
But, you know, do you ever wonder
how you see all these heavy women walking around
with their little skinny kids?
And the thing is, is that when kids are little,
if you don't, if you just offer them food,
they will eat what,
they'll eat when they're hungry
and, you know, they don't have a lot
of other issues going on.
So they just eat when they're hungry
and they have, you know, they wanna go play
and you know, if you let them do that, they'll self-regulate
and they'll be a healthy weight.
But then we start, you know, feeding them
the wrong kind of foods and doing things to them that,
you know, changing their behaviors
so that they eat unhealthy like we do.
And so it's a beautiful microcosm
to look at little kids,
unless we're doing something to them,
will maintain a healthy weight.
And so, but then the habits that we put on them
as they get older will often lead to weight gain.
So you have to look at the whole loop.
And then someone asked me about, you know,
about these behavioral, you know,
how do you find these behavioral weight loss programs and,
universities, almost all universities have
behavioral health programs for weight loss.
Look in your community.
And the CDC has a family healthy weight program
that will at least get you started.
But there are resources all over the place for these.
And definitely look online.
There are lots of now support groups
that are available online for individuals
that will be exceedingly helpful to families
who are dealing with this chronic issue.
I'm gonna ask Dr. Vail to take one last one
and then I got to turn it over to Dr. Garry.
I may have to...
Or I'll turn it over to-
I've lost my-
Dr. Garry-
Okay.
Joe.
So I'm gonna answer a couple here real quickly.
What's the most effective treatment over time
for chronic neck pain?
Superficial heat, and this one is different.
Acupuncture pops up to the top for chronic neck pain so.
What's your imaging test of choice
for a herniated disc?
Anywhere in the spine, it's gonna be MRI, non-contrast MRI.
What's the safest and most efficacious muscle relaxant
to use for acute low back pain?
(Dr. Weismiller and Dr. Garry laughing)
None, I mean, they all have their,
they all have their side effects.
I mean, so there isn't really one
that is safer than others or more effective than others.
It depends, you just have to read your patient.
I mean, if they're really anxious
and they need some more maybe sedative properties,
then maybe I'll use cyclobenzaprine or tizanidine.
If they don't seem like they need that,
I may choose something different,
but there's really no good answer to that question
because as a class, they all have problems,
especially as I get into older patients.
And is there one you don't recommend?
No, not necessarily.
What I would tell you is never prescribe
cyclobenzaprine in a 10 milligram dose,
prescribe it in five and let the patient titrate
because, you know,
you're gonna give them 10 milligram pills,
they're gonna get dizzy or tired,
or you have some urinary retention
and they'll never take it again.
And they might have gotten good relief from it so.
Can venlafaxine be used in chronic back pain
in place of duloxetine as an SNRI?
Great question.
I can tell you that the evidence that at 37 1/2 milligrams
or 75 milligrams, the answer is no,
but beyond that, it hasn't been studied.
So the question is, is this a drug effect
or is it a class effect?
And so we run into these,
we don't have a clear answer to that.
So does it make sense that I might consider that?
Sure, it makes sense.
I mean, if I have alternate uses
for putting them on the venlafaxine
as opposed to just managing the low back pain,
then I might consider that
if they don't tolerate the duloxetine.
I don't know the answer to it.
We haven't studied it to give you the answer yet.
And then the last question I'll hit here is I use ibuprofen
in combination with acetaminophen to treat pain
because the combination seems to work well.
So the answer, I agree.
Okay.
This is multimodal pain therapy
and we use multimodal pain therapy
in acute and chronic pain.
And so it works,
but when I put them head to head,
acetaminophen and ibuprofen,
acetaminophen gives no relief in acute low back pain
and ibuprofen gives significant relief in low back pain.
So when I combine them together,
is it the ibuprofen or the non-steroidal
that's really providing all the analgesia
and not the acetaminophen?
I don't know.
Is it really problematic?
No, it's not really problematic to put them together
because again, that's the basis
of multimodal analgesic therapy.
Dr. Vail, anything else?
I have a quick one on,
I had several people ask about
referral to bariatric surgery,
you know, so,
what EF is too low for that,
what, you know,
what A1C do you have to have to get them there
and that's sort of,
and because bariatric surgery is becoming
so much more mainline now,
I gave you the criteria,
which they might ask on the boards.
But when you have a patient
who really wants bariatric surgery,
now, if they have end stage something
and they're not gonna get any benefit,
they're gonna die before they, you know,
they lose weight and get benefit from it.
Well, that is clear.
But if you are like on the fence and you're, you know,
I'm not sure they'll do bariatric surgery on you or not,
but it would be beneficial for you,
send them on, the bariatric surgeons will make that,
they'll make the judgment call on that.
And looking at a lot of your questions,
I would encourage you all to come to Family Medicine Update.
We're having that discussion this year and we're doing it,
we're doing, one of our discussions this year is looking at
imaging modalities in musculoskeletal pain.
So that conference is the last week of April.
It's virtual this year
and then next year will be in June 2025.
That is going to be a live and virtual course.
So a lot of your questions we are answering
at that particular course which looks at
what is ready for practice.
And you have many of those questions you're putting forward.
I promise you guys,
there's gonna be a question on the exam
about Ottawa Ankle Rules, that will be on there.
It is always on there.
So I would know those Ottawa Ankle Rules.
And the way the question is normally positioned is
they give you tenderness over the anterior aspect
of the distal fibula.
Okay, it has to be over the posterior aspect, okay?
And you know, the data shows this has been shown
to decrease the risk of getting an x-ray of the foot
by about 30%, so that's good.
Okay, Dr. Vail, I'm gonna have you take it away, ma'am.
Diabetes.
All right, first thing is,
do we need two fasting glucose values to diagnose diabetes?
You need two values.
You can do a fasting and A1C.
Yes, I realize there are patients that come in
and you know, their sugar is 400
and do you really need another value?
No, but you're going to get another value
because you're going to be monitoring them.
So the answer for the test is yes,
you have to have two values
and there are those people that show up with an A1C of 6.5
and then we don't wanna put the diagnosis
of diabetes on them
because we could do a lot of things to keep them
from having that diagnosis
and that has a lot of implications
with their insurance, et cetera.
I always tell people there's a lot of tumble down
all of a sudden when you get that diagnosis,
you know, in terms of vaccines, medications,
et cetera, et cetera.
And then FARXIGA can be used in diabetes down to GFR
according to UpToDate.
Yeah, so these numbers are all changing
and they're pushing the GFRs down lower and lower.
And you'll notice, I mean, I had 60, 45,
and then down at the bottom it's like, you know,
use them down to 30.
So there are gonna be differences between what it says to
on the package insert and what we're using them to.
So I realize that's confusing,
but we're trying to use them down to a GFR of 30.
And someone asked about the point about contraceptives.
If you have a teenager on an ACE or an ARB,
then you have to make sure they're on a contraceptive
so they don't get pregnant on the ACE and ARB.
And the recommended would be an IUD or an Nexplanon,
not just an oral contraceptive.
I had a patient leave her obstetrician not recently,
and the ACE was continued as she was trying to get pregnant.
They had taken her for birth control and she saw me
and I'm like, "Your blood pressure's not controlled
and you should not be on that medication any longer."
She said "What?"
Okay.
And then hep B,
why do we give the vaccine in adults?
Because it's really because diet,
people with diabetes are going to deal
with a lot of needles,
either insulin or now with the GLP ones or finger sticks
or, you know, there's just too much of that
and it's so easy to just vaccinate for hepatitis B.
We already know how good vaccines are, right?
Yes.
So we should give
the vaccine.
Well, and keep in mind, in 2023,
ASIP finally said, "You know what, we've got so many groups,
everybody can get vaccinated with hepatitis B now."
You know, we caught everybody up after we did the kids
and everybody didn't get caught up.
So there's this window of about 35 or 40 till about 60
that people have not been immunized.
Now, anybody can get the hep B vaccine
per the ASIP recommendations if you haven't had one, okay?
You never get more than two series.
So if you don't respond to the first series,
you can get a second series,
but you never get more than two,
and there is no recommendation to routinely evaluate
for response to the hepatitis B series, okay?
And the last thing I'm just gonna say, no one,
we don't have a USPSTF recommendation or anything for B12,
checking B12 in people who are metformin.
And so should we do it every year?
I don't know, some of the newer studies are suggesting that,
but this is the problem.
There are thousands of diabetics out there
who are on metformin who've never had a B12 checked.
And so I don't care if their CBC looks okay,
people who have not had a B12 check
who are on metformin need that to happen.
Dr. Garry.
Okay, so several questions here.
One on individuals who are ordering x-rays.
And then I have to wait
and I've got to wait maybe days to get a radiology,
a radiologist's interpretation of the x-ray.
What should I do with it?
Well, I think, A, I'm ordering the x-ray,
it's imperative that I look at the x-ray.
So you have to have access to the x-ray.
You're gonna have to make a judgment
without having the radiologist's interpretation.
It's recognized, so this question's leading
to medical legal risk.
It's recognized that, that you're not a radiologist.
In the practice I came from at Minnesota,
we read our own images.
We could request an overread by radiology,
but we read our own images
and then subsequently, we billed for that portion of it.
But, so we can do that as a family medicine physician
or primary care physicians,
but it's imperative if you're ordering the imaging study
that you're looking at it
and you're making an interpretation.
If I overtreat, okay, I overtreat, I'm not a radiologist,
but you know, I don't,
I can't order it and say, "Well, you know,
there's this big mass there and I just,
I didn't know what it was,
so I didn't do anything about it for three or four days
until the radiologist said,
'There's a big mass there,'" right?
"You got to do this."
So you have to do that.
That's, I guess all I can say about that.
DXA is used for screening osteoporosis to avoid fractures,
but doesn't a fragility fracture
by definition confirm osteoporosis?
Yes, it does from a clinical standpoint,
but now I'm gonna implement treatment, I wanna get the DXA.
The DXA is a relatively inexpensive test
for everything that we do.
I don't know, I mean, my best insurance pays
maybe 300 bucks for a DXA with the interpretation.
Most of them pay less than that.
So it's a quick, it's an easy test.
And I have quantitative data to compare to my follow-up
two years later, sometimes one year later,
depending on the severity of it.
And I can see exactly what's happening.
Am I reforming bone?
Is my bone density actually going up?
And the key to this is once you get a DXA on a patient,
you want the second DXA
or subsequent DXA should be on the same machine.
So ask them where they had it
and then work with your insurer.
And your insurer will pay anybody
to get the DXA on the same machine,
even if they switch insurances.
Dr. Blackwelder.
Yeah, we'll talk more about osteoporosis
in my next lecture.
So some of my questions Dr. Garry gave you the answer to.
We'll see how closely you listened.
There, the most popular question was,
what degree of hearing loss do you recommend hearing aids
to reduce the risk of dementia?
We used to have a lecture on dementia in the board review,
but it was so depressing.
I mean, it was depressing.
Well-
It didn't,
any lecture on dementia is depressing.
And it hasn't gotten any better.
No.
It would've gotten more,
the things I would've had to say
this time would've been even more depressing.
Although, I'm very aggressive with this.
So if I have a patient
and there's any element of hearing loss,
I mean, we're quick to get hearing testing
and really advocating for them to get
some kind of hearing aids to help them.
I didn't include this in my,
I have a slide about dementia prevention in my last lecture,
but this has come to my attention
since I submitted my slides.
The Lancet every few years does
a dementia prevention summary
and they just had one they published in 2022
and they go through, it was like 12 things now
that we're having emerging evidence
to reduce the risk of dementia.
If we really focused on those things like hearing loss,
don't smoke, exercise, diet,
we could prevent 40% of dementias worldwide.
Now imagine if we had a medicine all of a sudden
that prevented 40% of dementias.
Think about the money behind that, right?
So I'm becoming more and more aggressive with this,
with the hearing aids and those type of things.
I also think this ties in a lot out of COVID.
We've learned the risk of social isolation
and cognitive impairment.
So if somebody can't hear, they're more likely to seclude
and not interact with their friends.
So all of this just spirals.
So good question, that was a popular one.
The other was asking for some clarification
about Medicare plans, (chuckles)
which is complicated
as the healthcare marketplace has grown,
there are now independent insurance brokers
to help guide patients through this.
If you can find somebody trustworthy,
they're a good resource potentially
'cause what happens is people don't know
what they're getting.
So then all of a sudden, a few years later they're like,
"Oh, I need rehab because I didn't have a DXA
and now I have a hip fracture."
And their insurance is a pain paying for their rehab.
So again, if you can encourage your person
to get the best plan and all the bells and whistles
as early as possible,
that's gonna benefit them down the road.
Another thing too, for these Medicare Advantage plans,
a lot of them require more pre-auths,
they also are geographic dependent.
So potentially, their plan is administered in,
let's say, South Carolina,
and they go visit their daughter in Ohio
for months out of the year.
They might not be able to get care
as opposed to just traditional Medicare A and B.
They can get care anywhere.
So it's complicated and in fairness,
we don't learn enough about this.
What I reviewed in my lecture,
kind of those basic nuts and bolts,
those would be the things that would be on your board exam.
Dr. Garry, you have another one?
Sure.
Vertebral compression fractures,
do you use a TLSO,
a thoraco-lumbo-sacral orthoses or a back brace?
You can for pain.
And usually, we make that determination very quickly.
Patient's gonna have to be admitted to the hospital
for the most part and they're gonna have to have enough pain
that I'm trying to get them up and get them moving.
So I wanna get them fitted with this brace
so that they can get up and get moving.
You're usually not using it very long,
so it's a really expensive intervention,
but if it helps me get them moving, then it's beneficial.
And then, of course,
you know, the questions about bisphosphonates,
can I use them?
Can I go from PO to IV and tack on another five years?
No, the answer is it's IV or PO, it's five,
you add it all up, it's five years.
And then what about vertebral plasty?
And no one asked about kyphoplasty.
But again, are you gonna talk about vertebral plasty?
I'm not, not that-
Okay.
I specifically don't talk about it.
I know it's still being done.
There's not any good evidence that it's beneficial
or it changes any outcomes and it's expensive.
And so I don't advise it,
but it's still being done so.
Dr. Vail, you have one last one?
Well, someone asked about the oral semaglutide.
So there is an oral form,
it's marked as RYBELSUS for diabetes
and it just doesn't work as well
as the injectable form, particularly for weight loss.
So unfortunately, it's not,
I don't think it's gonna get licensed for weight loss
'cause it just doesn't work that well.
So too bad.
And Dr. Blackwelder, one last thing?
You're good, okay.
Please join me in thanking our speakers.
They're all gonna be back this afternoon.
(audience applauding)
But if you're gonna stick around for questions and answers,
I'm going to turn to Dr. Vail first
and ask if she will take her top two.
Go for it, ma'am.
Cleared for surgery,
I don't like that term.
And a better term is really optimization for surgery.
And so if you are uncomfortable putting cleared for surgery,
write that the patient is optimized for surgery.
I actually will cross out the clear piece
and I put risk stratification
and that they're optimized for surgery.
I mean, that's what you can say about it.
Oh, you have one more?
Go ahead, I'll-
No,
okay, I'm gonna turn it to actually, Dr. Blackwelder.
So I got, I'll do a couple.
When somebody asked, can Prolia be used first line
instead of bisphosphonates?
Yes, it can, okay.
Most recommendations are gonna recommend bisphosphonates
'cause they're easier,
especially the ones that have been around a while,
oral bisphosphonates and they're cheaper.
And then, to answer a good question, is it,
when do you repeat the DXA
if somebody had a completely normal DXA at the age of 65?
There are no good guidelines for that, okay?
So a lot of my patients are new to me
at the age of, they move in,
and I see them for the first time when they're 85.
And I say, "When's your last DXA scan?"
And they say, "I don't remember."
I'm getting a DXA scan on them.
Or even if they had a normal one at 65,
they lived a lot longer
than they thought they were going to,
it's reasonable to get a DXA scan.
So there's really no good guideline.
I'd be shocked if it showed up on your test
and I'll answer all the rest of them online.
Dr. Garry.
How does Little League elbow differ from golfer's elbow?
You're at the right location,
but remember, it's the apophysis versus the tendon.
Little League elbow is an apophysitis.
It's not affecting the tendon,
the tendon's pulling the two pieces
of bone away from each other.
And it's that apophysis that is the pathology.
Whereas in golfer's elbow,
it's actually the tendon that is the pathology
that has some chronic degenerative change in it.
And then question about why the sed rate and CRP,
wouldn't the CRP be good enough?
Look, I'm just giving, (chuckles)
I'm giving you the data that the board likes.
In actuality, there have been, there was a follow-up study
that looked just at CRP and weight bearing status.
And if my CRP is normal and I'm weight bearing,
the likelihood of a septic hip is less than 1%.
So I like that data markedly better,
but this is the data that you're gonna be asked about.
So that's why I'm giving you that piece.
I'm just trying to toggle back to the other session.
While he's doing that, I'll just say stop warfarin
five days prior to surgery, stop aspirin and clopidogrel,
if you're stopping them separately,
those are both five to seven days.
So for sports related concussion, do you really,
what's the limitation on activity?
24 to 48 hours of no activity
and limit all their cognitive stuff,
no TV, no computer use, no telephone, screen use,
limit all that for 24 to 48 hours.
How do I decide?
It depends, however it works.
You can say 24, you can say 48.
It's really not any different.
At that point in time,
tell them I want you to start participating
in some kind of light activity
that doesn't make your symptoms worse, okay?
So 24 to 48 hours rest
and then they start light activity at that point in time
to a threshold that doesn't make their symptoms worse.
And then should there be imaging, it's great question,
should be there imaging if I have loss subconsciousness
with a sports related concussion?
The answer is,
this is the technical answer.
If I don't have focal neurologic signs or symptoms
when I awaken,
then no, there should be no imaging.
What would most of us do?
Most of us would probably image in that case.
Thankfully, you don't have loss subconsciousness
with sports related concussion very often.
And it typically occurs in the second, third,
or fourth concussion, not in the first one.
So Russell, please go ahead.
Thank you, sir.
All right, good question,
I harped a lot on things that we overdo in older adults,
that's much easier to talk about that.
Somebody asked when I stop statins?
Which is a very good question.
That typically is like the last medicine I stop,
I stop it when somebody's on hospice
and the side effects are low,
it is preventing them from having cardiovascular events.
If anything, we're probably undertreating with statins.
If you look at people for secondary prevention,
a lot of people are not on a statin who should be.
So I appreciated that question.
And then, other, you know, tell me,
at what age
does the Beers Criteria start to apply to people?
Technically, 65.
We all know certain folks or maybe younger than that
and we can apply the Beers Criteria, okay.
But 65 is technically the right answer.
And just wanted to highlight again too,
somebody asked about creatinine clearance versus GFR
really depends on the medicine you're looking at.
I would not think you would need to know specifics
like that for your board exam,
but I don't think they would
like which medicines depend on creatinine clearance,
which on GFR?
I would think you'd have other clues in your question still,
which would lead you to narrow in on your answer.
Yeah, I think that's highly unlikely.
Yeah.
Okay.
Dr. Gilmer.
First question is about PSA, checking PSA,
if you have a family history of prostate cancer.
Just keep in mind that if you biopsy to every 80-year-old,
most of them would have some evidence of prostate cancer,
not all of which would be malignant.
Keep that in mind.
Given that, that contributes to,
in the 55 to 69 age group,
that contributes to the conversation that you're gonna have
and whether they want to potentially risk stratify
and then counseling them on the potential risk,
the morbidity associated with a biopsy
that leads to a surgery.
Okay, just to, I just wanna emphasize here though.
On the exam, they're gonna ask you 55 to 69 every other year
if you're going to do it,
if you're gonna do it, okay.
Don't get, don't be adding things to the question, okay?
Regardless, 55 not before,
not after 69, every other year at the most, okay?
And there you save about one life
for a thousand people you screen, okay?
So keep that in mind
before you get off into the woods and miss the question
'cause you're adding stuff to the question.
Sorry about that, sir. Go ahead. (laughs)
Dr. Weismiller is fired up about that.
(Dr. Weismiller laughing)
Well, I don't want them to miss it
and I have seen too many people who have come back
and they'll have a question like,
"I'll have a question like that online
as part of our home study program,"
and people will start adding nuances to it.
I'm like, you've got to take it at faced value, okay.
You got to take the question at face value, okay.
That's the point I wanna make here.
Greater than 70, always the recommendation.
A couple questions about different types of stones
like HCTZ, uric acid stones,
is there a correlation between the two?
So this is a good question because if you have a stone,
the reason why you want to identify what type of stone it is
is because each of the five different types of stones
that can be formed all come from a very specific process.
If you have a calcium phosphate stone,
remember we talked about increased pH forms
calcium phosphate stones.
If you have increased oxalate,
which comes from sweet tea.
Sweet tea has a lot of oxalate,
so does rhubarb pie and stuff like that,
that's my home place,
that puts you at greater risk of a calcium oxalate stone.
If you have gout, you have a greater risk of a, you know,
of a uric acid stone.
If you have an infection,
you have a greater risk of a struvite stone, et cetera.
If you're a hyper cystine producer,
you have a greater risk of cystine stone.
So that's why it is important
to actually identify the type of stone that you have.
I'm gonna turn it over to you, I'm gonna look at that.
Dr. Blackwelder,
I'll have you take one more and then if you'll switch over
to your other talk, Dr. Gilmer.
Yep, so somebody asked about
prolonged QT with Zofran looking at risks.
And this is worth mentioning
'cause I see this from our residents a lot
and there's so many medicines that have a prolonged QT risk,
you know, according to our pharmacist and talking to him,
the studies with prolonged QT with,
on ondansetron were like 32 milligrams
of people getting that dose, you know,
and my response to that is, you know,
that's why we have EKGs.
So if you're concerned about it,
get the EKG and make sure
and then choose the safer option.
It also goes back to the additive effect
of being on multiple medicines that prolong QT.
So maybe you really look at it
and you start whittling away on what people are on
to decrease that risk.
Dr. Gilmer,
remember Odansetron is FDA approved
for one indication, nausea associated with chemotherapy.
(Dr. Blackwelder chuckles)
There were several questions.
I think it took some time for you to enter
into the question.
So if you weren't able to ask a question,
you can go back and check
because now you can certainly do it
if your poll was not working appropriately.
Lots of really good questions here.
Can hydroxychloroquine be used as a first line agent?
I think this is a good question
because you always want to use as a non-biologic agent,
you always want to use your methotrexate first.
If methotrexate is not getting the job done,
then add second hydroxychloroquine.
If there's some contraindication to methotrexate,
it's okay to start with hydroxychloroquine,
but methotrexate, your number one,
hydroxychloroquine will be your number two,
and then sulfasalazine would be your number three
if you're gonna pursue triple therapy.
Couple questions about, yes,
you can add DMARDs biologic ones to non-biologic ones.
If you are on triple therapy, however,
you really don't wanna have someone
on triple non-biologic therapy plus a biologic agent.
You would do one non-biologic agent
plus a biologic agent.
I hope that makes sense.
Oh, here's a good question.
Any data on autologous plasma injections and osteoarthritis.
Dr. Garry would love that question.
There actually is some data
with autologous plasma injections in osteoarthritis,
but just as you have with like hyaluronic acid or steroids,
the lasting treatment or effects is very small.
So you're gonna see more, you're gonna see greater benefit
with autologous plasma injections for tendinopathies
and less effect with an osteoarthritis.
If you have chronic severe osteoarthritis,
the only thing that's gonna cure
that is a joint replacement.
Everything else is really just very superficial.
What is the uric acid lowering agent treatment of choice?
Again, allopurinol, it's the cheapest.
Most people tolerate it really well.
There's a genetic marker if you're concerned
and it's the place to go.
If, however, you're not getting to the place,
if you're not able to get
your uric acid below six on allopurinol
and you've increased the dose say up to 600 milligrams,
if that's the case and they're still symptomatic,
that will be a good time to switch to Uloric
because there's some studies that show you
that you can push the dose of Uloric a little bit higher
and gain a little additional efficacy at the higher doses.
So that will be kind of a niche for Uloric or- (indistinct)
All right, is there a benefit
to steroid injections for acute gout?
Yes, so again, efficacy is the same with steroids,
NSAIDs, colchicine, they're all the same.
But yes, there's benefit
with intra-articular steroid injections in the acute phase.
And with that,
we're going to have to bring things to a close.
I'm gonna turn it over to Dr. Dachs to get started
with the peripheral vascular disease lecture.
The quick, first quick questions.
What's the difference between an aortic aneurysm
and an ectasia?
So an ectasia is a dilation of an artery,
let's say the aorta,
but it's not greater than 50% of the,
the diameter of the lumen.
So it's a little bit of a dilation.
It's not a true aneurysm yet.
Actually, the radiologists are encouraged not to use
that term anymore
'cause it just confuses the heck out of everybody.
What's the difference between an eccentric
and saccular type of aneurysm?
They're the same thing.
It's just one wall of the vessel comes out.
Not a fusiform, the whole thing circumferentially dilating.
Those are the difference between the two.
ABI, is it done sitting, standing or lying down?
You typically glide the patient down to get to their legs.
Definition of ever smoked?
It's 100 cigarettes in a lifetime.
If you have an ABI greater than 1.4,
do you send the patient for duplex sonography?
Yeah, you start working them up, yes.
How long do you prescribe cilostazol for?
If it's working, kind of indefinitely.
Unless then they go for some surgery and corrective stuff
and then you get the stop, right?
I think that's where I'll stop there
and I'll go over to my colleague-
Dr. Gilmer.
Shall, I answer
the rest of these online.
You guys had some great questions,
probably more questions than any other group we've had.
I answered all of them online.
There are a couple,
there were many questions on subclinical hypothyroidism.
So when you are subclinically hypothyroid,
that means you technically don't have symptoms.
So if you don't have symptoms
and your TSH is floating higher, say nine,
you don't have to treat that.
So there's that.
If they become symptomatic
and they have a TSH of nine,
then clearly, you need to treat that.
If a patient is in a higher risk state,
i.e, cardiovascular disease, osteoporosis, et cetera,
you can consider getting a TPO antibody
because a TPO antibody just further risk stratifies
if they might progress towards fulminant hypothyroidism.
So that's the nuance there.
In a way you shouldn't even know about those people.
You shouldn't be screening for hypothyroidism
unless there's overt disease.
I recently had a patient
who said I cannot tolerate levothyroxine.
She was on this low dose.
I'm like, "Why are you on it?"
They said, well, they said, "I had hypothyroidism."
TSH was 13, completely asymptomatic.
I did a search, she's got a 20% chance
of developing hypothyroidism.
But there was no indication to treat her at this point,
even with the TSH of 13.
And most of these patients come in, you can find them,
they're on 25 micrograms of levothyroxine
and you're like, "How did they diagnose you?"
Dr. Gilmer, continue.
You can always just consider surveillance too,
two, three months as we, as in that previous patient.
Much questions about thyroid nodule, like what do you do?
What is the surveillance pattern
after you identify a nodule,
it's a nodule that that doesn't look concerning,
it's less than one centimeter.
The Academy of Clinical Endocrinology has a whole list
of criteria that will help guide you
as to what you need to do, the morphology of the lesion,
the size of the lesion, et cetera.
Otherwise, all of your other discreet questions
I answered online.
Dr. Dachs.
So someone asked about
the ischemic stroke question number five.
Is the answer not aspirin
since I put in the dosages 325 versus 81?
When they come in the ER, we give them,
we typically have them chew
four 81 milligram tablets, so 324.
We give them a full dose aspirin
for an acute ischemic stroke.
And that's what people usually started on
with their acute ischemic strokes, not 81 milligrams.
What's the role of Plavix clopidogrel
in acute stroke?
I hope I cleared this up.
If it's an NIHSS score greater than three,
I'm not giving Plavix for acute stroke.
If it's a TIA or an NIHS score less than three,
then I will use clopidogrel
as part of my dual anti-platelets, okay?
That clear?
I hope that's clear now.
I love this one, do Good Samaritan laws vary
if the plane is an international flight? (laughs)
Generally not.
But I will tell you there's actually, Australia,
I know Australia and I think there's a couple of others
if you're on Qantas for example, you have a duty to assist
and you can get in trouble if they find out you're a doctor
and you didn't assist.
Okay, they have, you must assist in certain countries,
but Qantas I know is one of them.
It's kind of interesting.
My very first assist was leaving a board review course
and I had to assist twice on the plane
with two different people.
Oh really?
I've never done that before.
Yeah
Craziness.
Well, you know, for those of you who've done this,
I mean-
I got a $500 voucher on a flight to Singapore
for assisting with-
Yeah, definitely.
I've done three times.
Once I got a voucher, once I got nothing,
twice I got nothing.
You get nothing.
And doing it, it's really tough.
There is like no space, you have to find a spot.
Like you have to take the patient
and move them into, you know, an area
if you're doing resuscitation or CPR, it's not easy.
I will tell you one other funniest story
if I can, just about this.
So my wife is an ICU nurse
and one of the things they called the doctor for,
there's a woman right across from us
who was having a panic attack.
It was just, she was just, it was,
she was all over the place, it was terrible, you know.
And so my wife has much more empathy than I do.
You're kidding me.
But yeah, (laughs) sat there, talked her the whole flight,
the whole flight.
So we, you know, I assessed the woman, of course,
my wife did the whole thing.
We get off the plane, my wife is PO'd to this day.
Everybody came up to me and said, "Great job, doc."
"Great job, doc."
And didn't say anything to my wife. (laughs)
So true story.
All right, enough of that.
Do I have time for one or two more, David?
I don't know where I'm at time-
You have time for one more.
Okay. (chuckles)
Does considering anticoagulation change
if you have paroxysmal AFib versus persistent AFib?
That's a great question.
Most of the cardiologists
and most everybody says even for paroxysmal AFib,
you should consider putting them on anticoagulation.
Yes, that's the answer on that one, yeah.
David, can I just make one addendum to one answer
I guess just gave here about the Plavix in acute stroke?
Yes.
Take two seconds, I'm sorry.
I said we don't use Plavix in acute stroke
with an NIHS score greater than three, the big strokes.
One caveat or exception to that rule is
if the patient has an aspirin allergy,
then you would use the clopidogrel.
There's a nuance.
Thank you very much, we'll be back at 10 o'clock.
Okay, lots of questions here.
Probably four times as many as we normally get
for one of these talks.
So you guys have been paying attention.
There are a lot of questions in the CKD lecture about,
again, the use of ACEs and ARBs and when do you do that?
Patients who have diabetes and hypertension,
patients who have diabetes and CKD,
those are individuals who would benefit
from an ACE or an ARB.
Patients who have chronic kidney disease
not related to diabetes.
Those individuals will also benefit from a certain ARB,
especially, if they have the presence of albuminuria
or that they are hypertensive.
Patients who have diabetes,
but do not have hypertension,
do not have CKD,
do not have albumin in their urine,
do not need to be on ACEs or ARBs to prevent kidney disease
in the future, okay?
And you may or may not see that on the board.
How about the workup for CKD when do you start doing that?
Generally, when a patient hits CKD three
on the basis of their GFR,
those folks should have a reasonable workup
both in terms of labs and probably an imaging study
to look at their kidneys, probably an ultrasound,
but patients with CKD one or two,
who have that diagnosis on the basis
of having polycystic kidney disease
on the basis of having persistent albuminuria,
even if they have a decent GFR,
you know, those folks still probably should get a workup
at the time that you identified that abnormality,
Dr. Dachs.
And so this goes back to the first lecture.
How are we supposed to measure compartments?
Are we supposed to measure
compartment syndromes in the office?
I don't know of any office setting that has this set up
to do a compartment syndrome measurement.
We do it in the ER, it is a very simple thing.
You just put a needle in.
We used to hook it up to manometer,
but now there's this electronic little piece
to do it in there and gives you the pressure.
Are you diagnosing retinal hemorrhages in young children
on CT or ophthalmoscope?
(coughs) Excuse me.
So retinal hemorrhages, you got to do an ophthalmoscope,
that's the way you do it
if you have intracerebral hemorrhages you'll find it on CT.
What's, and this one's I don't have the right answer for.
Where is the line for a dirty wound versus clean?
There's no line.
I mean, it's dirty versus clean.
I mean, what do you think is dirty clean?
Is there no lifting restriction needed
for patients with hernia?
No, there's not, I know,
I know we've been telling patients for years, don't lift.
If you've got a hernia, you'll make it worse.
You know, they can lift, they can, you know,
would I tell them to be go, you know,
be a professional weightlifter
and start, you know, bench pressing 300 pounds?
No, no I wouldn't do that,
but a simple exercise and mild lifting is just fine.
Excuse me.
Why no Betadine to clean the wound again?
There's a couple of people ask that.
Betadine into the wound is cytotoxic.
If you dilute out the Betadine like 100 to one,
you can put it in, that's all right.
Betadine on the intact skin around the wound is fine,
but pouring it into the wound is what I'm referring to
is not where you wanna go with that.
How do you know it's a descending cholangitis
versus just cholecystitis?
Again, Charcot's triad.
If they've got, you know, if they're jaundiced,
and they're, you know,
then you know what you're dealing with.
And I think I've sort of answered that for the most part.
Yeah, that's, I'll move on to my next one.
Dr. Levine.
Yeah, there's a question about metformin
and checking a creatinine GFR.
When do you do that?
You should know the patient's creatinine
in order to safely treat them with metformin.
So if you don't have one recently before you start,
then go ahead and get one, you know,
within a short period of time
to make sure it's safe to continue on their therapy.
Question about hydration in relation to contrast studies.
How much do you use?
There's no specific regimen or protocol for that.
Most of the studies that have looked at it have indicated
that it's safe,
doesn't cause people to go into pulmonary edema.
And usually, they're using doses about a milliliter
per kilogram per hour.
So 75 to a 100 mls per hour.
Maybe start a couple hours before the procedure,
continue for, you know, a couple hours or more afterwards.
If you have a hospitalized patient, it's easy to do that.
In outpatient, you're probably not gonna hydrate them
for as long
and whatever isotonic solution you like will work.
Question about what to do in the setting of AKI
with volume overload.
Do you treat the volume overload first with diuretics
or you treat the AKI?
Well, you treat the volume overload,
especially if it's pulmonary edema
because if you do that you may improve their cardiac output
to renal perfusion and the AKI may get a whole lot better.
But while you're doing that,
you're also looking for other reasons for the AKI
and you're treating those
so to help the patient get better quicker.
Do you have to memorize normal ranges of values
related to protein excretion for the boards?
Yeah, I would know what difference
between normal microalbuminuria and macroalbuminuria.
I think that's fair game for you.
The others probably not as much.
Dr. Dachs.
Okay.
Do we see similar MRSA proliferation outside
of the United States?
I don't know the answer to that question.
I can look it up but I really don't know.
This is actually a good question and the next one.
Up where I am now in my neck of the woods,
when you see a seven nerve cranial palsy
and are not sure if it's Lyme or Bell's palsy,
how do you treat them while you wait for my results?
You're absolutely right.
It is a real quandary
and we do our best to try to get some sort of sense.
Is this person at risk for Lyme disease?
Are they outside a lot?
Are they, you know, it becomes, it's a clinical call
and as you know, if you think it's a Bell's,
then you should start them on steroids.
When it comes to Lyme, there's been actually some suggestion
that you shouldn't start the steroids
and so it leaves us in a real quandary
and you just do your best clinical judgment
on whether you think this person is,
falls on one side of the equation or the other.
It's not a good situation to be in.
Let's do the next one.
Does Jarisch-Herxheimer reaction only occur with penicillin
or does it occur with doxycyline?
Any antibiotic that's gonna kill those spirochetes.
Again, they're exploding, they're dying,
and you're not, it's gonna happen.
I did not know this, maybe some can look this up for me.
According to UpToDate,
amoxicillin should be edited to doxycycline
for MRSA cellulitis.
Do you agree with this?
And since I'm not aware of that yet.
I haven't seen that recommendation, I'm not sure why.
Be careful with UpToDate though when you're using it,
because there is some opinion
in there.
Opinion, yeah.
That is not necessarily evidence-based.
Yeah.
So be careful
if you're gonna, particularly on the longitudinal exam,
you're going to that as your resource.
Yeah.
There is opinion in there and you will see it.
They'll say, "In our practice here at."
Right.
"We do this."
Okay, so be careful
with that, okay?
Right.
Yeah, and that was the example I gave
with the cat scratch.
Yeah, they said, yeah, give antibiotics
where you look at other textbooks and they say no,
you don't do it.
At one or two more here,
it is really, this is a good question.
What is the recommended duration of antibiotics
for MRSA cellulitis?
7 days or 14 days?
Everybody in general,
shorten the courses of your antibiotics please.
No more 14 days for cellulitis.
Five to seven is fine, okay.
It is good.
I'm gonna post a paper
from the American Board of Internal Medicine.
We did a presentation on this last year,
Family Medicine Update, looking at outpatient treatment,
five days of antibiotics,
which is really where things are moving.
So I'm gonna post that to one of the Q&As
before you guys leave.
Okay.
I'm gonna ask Bob to take one last one
and then Gary to take two and then we've got to do our call
because we're running low on time here.
Someone wrote, what about TXA,
tranexamic acid for angioedema?
It usually works in about 20 minutes.
There's been plus minus on that that's out there
as well as FFP is the other thing
people have talked about using angioedema.
And I'm talking about ACE-induced angioedema here,
plus minus the data is weak if anything, okay.
Dr. Levine.
Is proteinuria same thing as albuminuria?
No, it's not.
Albuminuria is the most common type of proteinuria,
but you can get proteinuria,
Bence-Jones proteinuria for example for myelomas.
That's not gonna show up on a dipstick.
And maybe very important for your patient.
What about a patient who has increased creatinine on a PPI?
What should you do?
Should you stop the PPI and recheck the BMP?
And the answer to that is yeah,
if you suspect that's the problem
because the creatinine bumped
after you started the PPI then stop it
and recheck your creatinine in a week to two weeks later.
But you might also look at the urine for eosinophils
and if it's positive then you know exactly
that that's the reason and then you can, you know,
then treat the patient normally after that.
Please join me in thanking our colleagues,
particularly, Dr. Dachs.
You will be taking leave from us.
(audience applauding)
Thank you.
I'm gonna ask Dr. Levine to go ahead and get started.
I have answered almost all of mine online
so please refer to that for your answers for my questions.
I have a couple more to do
but I will finish those up and Gary,
take it away please, sir.
Yeah, there are a couple questions as always come up.
What do you do if you have a patient on opioids,
you have a contract with them
and they test positive for marijuana THC?
The problem, the reason that you do
the urine drug testing is two reasons.
One is to find out if they're taking the medication
that you have them on
and the other,
are they taking something that they shouldn't?
Specifically things that could either interact
with the medicines that you're using
or suggest that they really have a preference
for some other drug
and they're gonna use your prescription
to sell on the street to finance the thing
that they really want.
You know, marijuana, when it was illegal,
it had more of a connotation of abuse
and you would worry
that your patient is gonna sell your oxycodone
and then buy their marijuana.
So what you do with a patient individually is look at
that individual risk
and if you're concerned
that you know, the marijuana use is gonna interfere
with what you're using,
you fear that they really are selling your drug
to buy marijuana,
then whether it's legal or it's illegal,
then you might not wanna continue the contract.
And if you're worried about that upfront,
you put that in the contract before you start,
say "Listen, you know,
you know I'm worried about you smoking marijuana
five times a day and it's not gonna work my opioid.
And if you do that and it shows up,
then we're gonna have to do this a little bit differently.
So I think you look at the individual patient,
you decide what the risk is and you can use that
to determine whether the contract stays in place
or is eliminated and how you work from there.
There is also a question about things
that may give you a false positive urine drug test.
The thing that really strikes you
or comes out is the patients who have colds and coughs
and they go to the drugstore and they get pseudoephedrine
and then they test positive
for methamphetamines in the urine.
And that's a fairly common thing
because some folks were using pseudoephedrine
and similar things to that at home to make methamphetamines,
it's pretty closely related
and at least in North Carolina,
if you go to get pseudoephedrine,
the pharmacist will take your picture and of your license
and tell you if you come back too often you get this again,
they're gonna report to the authorities
'cause it really was a big issue for us.
So that's the one that most commonly comes up.
Dr. Beste.
All right.
Do babies of iron deficient mothers need iron
sooner than four months?
The answer is no,
because babies are very efficient little parasites.
They will suck up all the iron they need
into their bodies before they're born.
So they're born with about four months worth of stores.
Somebody asked about amblyopia screening,
we're gonna talk about that in the next talk.
Is there formula that isn't iron or vitamin D fortified?
Yes, there is.
There are a lot of families out there who like to make
their own formula during the formula shortage
about a year ago,
we had all kinds of crazy formulas coming in.
So just ask and find out
what kind of formula they're taking.
We do get some people who like to go with some,
not necessarily standard formulas.
Do you continue iron supplementation on newborns
after they start eating solids?
You want to make sure
they're eating enough iron containing food.
So it depends on the diet.
Typically, around nine to 12 months
when they're eating table foods,
as long as the family's eating food with iron in it.
Youngest age, you start juice for constipation,
usually about four to six months
about the time you introduce food.
For breastfeeding moms is 6,400 international units
of vitamin D daily.
That's just what the research has shown.
My mom usually take a 5 to 10,000 capsule per day.
Can we rename breastfeeding jaundice
to lack of breastfeeding jaundice?
It's suboptimal intake jaundice, please.
Let's see, how often should you trend bilirubin levels
in the newborns?
Okay, this,
since we screen everybody at 24 hours of life,
this is where you would plug this into one of those tools
and it will basically tell you, you're good to go,
you need to recheck it in 12 to 24 hours,
whoa, you know, they're high enough,
we need to start thinking about lights.
I would highly recommend that you,
rather than trying to plot it out on a chart by yourself,
use one of the many great tools out there.
Is there a difference in colic rates between breastfed
and formula-fed babies?
Nope, they're all crazy.
I was a colic.
I was a colicky baby too.
My mother said that my son was payback for that.
(Dr. Weismiller laughs)
Dr. Levine, you weren't a colicky baby, were you?
I don't remember much when I was a baby.
(Dr. Weismiller and Dr. Beste laughing)
Your mother didn't bring
that out to you?
My parents never complained
about it. (Dr. Weismiller and Dr. Beste laughing)
They still sent me through school.
(Dr. Beste laughing)
You want me to do a few more?
I'm gonna ask you to do one more
and Jan to do one more
and then we got to call it because we got to take our break.
All right, the question whether it's important
on the boards that Nortriptyline is less anticholinergic
than amitriptyline is.
Yeah, I think that's important.
Clinically, it's important to know.
You wanna avoid anticholinergics in the elderly,
especially, anybody with dementia.
And I think the board's fair game, they ask you about that.
Jan, you got one more you wanna take?
I think a lot of these are much more
sort of detailed questions.
Okay.
I'm gonna answer online.
Fine.
Gary, do you have one more you wanna take?
There's one more about opinion
of family physicians doing ultrasound-guided
joint injections and steroid injections
for chronic pain management.
And we have first medicine docs,
family docs in our practice do exactly that
and do it pretty frequently.
So I think that it's a service
to your patients if you have the requisite skillset
and your ability to diagnose and treat appropriately, yeah.
Thank you very much.
I'm gonna promise you,
you're gonna see that dexamethasone question on the exam
and you're gonna see one on bronchiolitis too.
Those two will definitely be on there.
The other one, we'll learn about tomorrow
that's always on there almost,
is how do you treat allergic rhinitis?
How do you treat allergic rhinitis?
And the first line therapy is an intranasal steroid,
not an antihistamine, okay.
I promise you they're gonna ask you that question.
Yep.
So on every
in-training exam.
Dr. Levine is back.
I'm back.
Dr. Levine,
take it away, sir.
So what's the difference between
erythrasma and intertrigo?
They both look very similar and are in the similar areas.
Intertrigo may be a little moisture looking,
a little bit more itchy,
but the key is to do the Wood's lamp exam.
At the Wood's lamp,
looks like it's a coral pink, red fluorescence,
that's erythrasma rather than intertrigo.
A question about the difference
between lichen simplex chronicus and neural dermatitis,
they're actually very similar
and some people would consider them the same thing
and a chronic itchy rash that you scratch
and scratching makes it worse
and may either be in plaques or excoriations,
but they're very similar.
Question about shingles vaccine and how long will it last?
Shingrix, according to CDC, has about a 90% effectiveness
for about seven years.
Question about telling difference between
hot tub folliculitis
and hot tub pseudomonas folliculitis.
Whether I know how to do that is do a punch biopsy
the folliculitis and culture it.
But the assumption is that
the folliculitis is probably a gram negative.
Pseudomonas is in that group.
If you treat them with ciprofloxacin.
If they don't resolve initially,
the pseudomonas should be covered by the ciprofloxacin.
How long can scabies survive out of a host?
They say about two to three days.
So if you put in a plastic bag
or something for that period of time,
they'll suffocate or leave away from people
for that length of time.
And it's cruel and unusual punishment
for the scabies organism,
but two to three days.
(Dr. Beste laughs)
Dr. Beste.
All right, I'm gonna do a couple questions
from the well-child talk first,
just to clarify,
fiber doesn't help for constipation in newborns,
but it helps in children, adolescents, and adults?
So fiber is good for maintaining healthy bowel habits.
It doesn't treat constipation.
So that's when you would use your MiraLax,
your polyethylene glycol
for both young children and older children.
Fluoride does not lower IQ.
That was a question.
How do you screen for amblyopia?
That is, so for younger children,
you do the cover on cover test.
So you cover one eye and then you switch it
and you wanna make sure that both eyes should stay straight.
If one eye drifts away when you cover it,
that is someone you need to refer.
Why should walkers be avoided?
So kids and walkers can tip over and be injured.
You should not have children walkers.
(blabbers) When do you test for obstructive sleep apnea
with a sleep study?
If you get a,
it's just simply the same way you would for adults.
If you hear a lot of snoring, stopping breathing.
Also, if they have hypertension and they're obese,
you probably wanna screen for obstructive sleep apnea.
Multivitamins.
Some multivitamins also have recommended folic acid,
although they're not prenatal.
Yes, you can do that.
Any multivitamin that's got folic acid in it is fine.
Winter routinely screen for anemia.
So the American Academy of Pediatrics recommends
between six and 12 months.
So if you're going to screen,
that's the time that you're gonna screen for it.
When do you screen for lipids?
You screen for lipids risk-based in the younger ages
and then routinely again,
according to the American Academy of Pediatrics
between 8 and 11 and then 17 and 21 once each time.
What age should we start checking blood pressure
with a cuff?
You'd start that at age three.
(blabbers) One of my favorite questions, David,
you'll appreciate this.
No paps until 21 years.
Are we just doing speculum exams with HPV testing
or just no cytology or no pelvic exams at all?
So under the age of 21, you do not need to do
any pelvic screening at all with HPV, with pap smears.
Now that's different if they have a complaint
or there's a problem
'cause now you're doing diagnosis,
but you do not do any screening under the age of 21.
Dr. Levine.
There's a question about the use
of dermoscopy in diagnosing melanoma.
How many of you just be curious,
have been trained to do dermatoscopy
or able to do that in your practice?
How many?
So about 10%, the best 5% otherwise.
Yes, it's a very valuable tool if you have the skillset
and the training to do so.
Without that, still wanna pay attention
to the A, B, C, D, E, Us
if you look at patients in your practice
and if you have a concern
then referral to dermatology is certainly reasonable.
There's a question about
family medicine physicians doing,
treating acne with Accutane.
Do you need any special courses or a fellowship to do that?
No, you don't.
Gonna need an interest and willingness,
in order to do that, you do have to sign up for,
with the website in order to treat patients
without getting them seriously ill.
So you have to sign up with that.
And if you do that,
you can treat patients without any special courses.
Does perioral dermatitis typically worsen
with steroid application?
Yes, typically it does.
We don't know exactly what causes it,
but steroid use is one of those things
that does so frequently
I have answered most of mine.
I just wanna draw your attention to one particular question
because somebody asked about the issue
of bismuth subsalicylate for prophylaxis
of travelers diarrhea.
It can be used there.
It's just that the Centers for Disease Control
do not recommend routinely prophylaxing
with bismuth subsalicylate, okay.
So it can be used as a prophylaxis.
It's just not recommended routinely
to prophylax individuals against that.
You can use it for treatment if it is needed,
but the most important thing you can do
is make sure people are attentive to appropriate hygiene.
And in that context, hand washing, okay?
But it can be used for prophylaxis.
It's just, I wanna emphasize that it's not recommended
that we prophylax people routinely.
That is because when you prophylax people,
they become a bit more relaxed
and in general, they're then put themselves
at increased risk for infection, okay.
Jan, do you have any more you wanna tackle?
Everything else I think I've answered online.
If I have not yet, they're just one off.
So I'm gonna answer those
at some point when I finish up today.
There's a couple of questions about
do you treat other groups of strep on throat culture?
And the answer is really no.
It's really Group A strep is one that you treat.
The others are considered to be more colonizing.
So if you have Group G or Group B or Group Q or whatever,
you just tend to not worry about those as much.
There was one question and I wanted to make this
a little bit clear that the American Academy
of Pediatric size guidelines from August of 2021
regarding fever of unknown origin.
So that article is the one that I referenced.
That is that step by step method,
you'll notice that the article is the reference for that.
And so when they were risk stratifying these kids,
that's the method that they recommend using
to risk stratify whether these kids are at low risk
or high risk for serious bacterial infection.
And like I said, if you're interested,
the article was graded.
It is referenced on the slide.
Why do a test for celiac when the answer,
whether it's positive or negative,
is to do a gluten-free diet?
Well, if you have patients with celiac disease
or have family members with celiac disease,
you know, they can be exceedingly sensitive here
and you wanna know whether this is the diagnosis or not.
Because if it's a preference,
you know I don't have celiac disease,
but I feel better, they tend to be able to tolerate
some degree of gluten.
And you know, there are restaurants who cannot attend
to people who have celiac disease
and cannot attend to having no gluten, okay.
So it really is a huge lifestyle issue
in terms of what your sensitivity is like.
So you'd like to be able to tell the patient
whether they have the disease or don't have the disease,
I think it's really helpful in management
as well as you know,
despite the fact that food prices are quite high,
if you wanna get really high prices,
look at any gluten-free product in your local supermarket,
they are two times to three times
what would be the normal price.
So that's the reason behind all of this.
And you know, I'm very attuned to this
'cause my middle daughter has celiac disease
and she's very sensitive
and you've got to be very careful there
in terms of what degree they can tolerate.
The other question was,
if patient doesn't follow the diet for celiac,
are they at increased risk?
Okay, if they have celiac, they won't follow the diet,
because they are miserable otherwise.
And you can imagine if you're just constantly bloated
and with discomfort in the abdomen,
you do anything you can to avoid that. (coughs)
So they will follow the diet.
Okay, everything else, I'm gonna answer online.
Anything else from either of you?
Yeah, I just wanted to say I'm very impressed
with the questions from this group.
This is a very smart group.
Please join me in thanking both our speakers.
They're gonna be taking leave.
(audience applauding)
(soft music)